we now cross over to Athens to join
journalist Philip pangalos hello what's
the mood among Greeks at this stage good
morning to you drama anxiety and anger I
think Greeks are really really worried
about what's going on they feel that the
government has backed down so so far
beyond what it I said it was going to do
they pretty well put everything on the
table they've gone to these meetings in
Brussels and they feel that some of the
hardliners especially the Germans are
just trying to humiliate them and Prime
Minister Alexis tsipras faces a very
very difficult task and obviously the
hopes here are that they can find a
compromise deal and keep Greece in the
euro for now the problem he's going to
face is he had the backing of opposition
parties when they had a vote late on
Friday early Saturday he had 251 MPs out
of Greece's 300 MPs giving him a green
light to proceed with these negotiations
and do a deal the problem he still faces
he may well have to do some kind of
cabinet reshuffle this week because he
had a number of defectors from his own
series I party some of the hardliners
either voted against abstained or didn't
turn up and the fear is that he may lose
the majority within his coalition the
good thing is that there are plenty of
others willing to step in to support him
some of the opposition prophet said very
clearly that they'll do whatever it
takes to keep Greece in the euro of
course one of the big concern for the
Greeks I think one of the things they're
trying to negotiate as you said these
talks are ongoing we're hearing here
that Prime Minister Alexis tsipras is in
another closed meeting with French
president Hollande and German Chancellor
Merkel we don't live there be able to
reach these gaps but one of the big
concerns is the banks the banks we've
had capital controls for two weeks and
those are like the statements for a long
time regardless the banks remain closed
their restrictions on how many Greeks
can take out of ATMs the economies is in
freefall nothing's happened businesses
can't do business and the fear is unless
there's some kind of agreement or some
kind of promise that the ECB can
continue giving this emergency liquidity
Greek banks it's just a matter of time
before they collapse and obviously it's
going to be
very difficult to get this this new
legislation in front of parliament and
voted by mid-week i think it can be done
it's going to be difficult and hard
times ahead for both mr. TRS and for
Greeks well if Greece is forced to make
concessions as a result of these talks
how do you think this will affect Alexis
it presses popularity among the Greek
people he's popularity surprisingly is
riding high despite the fact this whole
business has been a complete mess and in
the five six months that he's been in
power all that's happened is that the
economic situation has gotten a lot
worse down the line he could be harmed
they've been talks of a possibly a
national unity government the most
important thing is we've seen Greeks
more than eighty percent of them want to
stay in the euro they I think they
understand up falling out the euro and
going back to a drachma and up another
currency would be disastrous so it's
going to be tough I think we're going to
have uncertain times over the coming
months but the priority for now is to
try and stay in the euro but there's
also feeling amongst Greeks that the
Germans and some of the hard liners are
just now trying almost to humiliate the
neisha nation and some of these measures
will hurt the economy they're going to
stay in recession there aren't enough
measures for growth and the big thing
here is or two things as measures for
growth and making Greece's debt
sustainable the best they're going to
get is a promise that that might happen
in the future but the immediate concern
is money to keep the banks alive for now